[Music]
in reality tryouts news submitted by is
it Christmas yet
I've been asked they should make
Christmas three months long
you wouldn't get sick of it after they
won pushes that oh yeah happy
anniversary
oh when we got together really it was
Christmas y'all just trying to take over
Jesus birthday like that no we're not
you put us together not even his
birthday it was real birthday like
sometime you know sometimes son I
thought that's when he came out of the
cave and rolled out the big rock let me
tell you something about New Year's
though that's my holiday why I love the
New Year's first you look like a [ __ ]
grandpa talking to us like that like
have your shoulders up to here
looks like somebody's taking you away
for being a genius this prison is using
VR to teach inmates how to live on the
outside oh that's fun
the lady with the purse don't take it
[ __ ] up it's not tantalizing then I'm
like I know you guys I know you guys are
in here but look how beautiful it is
outside guys like as soon as I take this
off it's another [ __ ] greasy ass
roommate the nasty-ass food what don't
go to prison anymore
oh by the law you're like what is it you
like speed like real sinner if there's
keys on the floor you don't pick it up
or you give it to the person who dropped
it I mean you don't pick it up you
[ __ ] horrible human being you pick it
up and you're like who's it's better
than stealing it [ __ ] funny okay so
anything what did you just 20 thing
things changed do any 18 of Mike's
moving on what do you think
yeah that's did I get Instant Karma
all right this prison in Colorado they
started this early release program for
people that have been convicted as
juveniles and they've already served
like 20 plus years in this sentence oh
[ __ ] 20 years that must have been a
really bad crime yeah these are like
people that are getting like pretty much
like life sentences okay you saw they
stabbed or back in the eighties in that
maybe okay yeah so then now in order to
prepare them for the possibility of
being released um this this program this
VR program thing they put them in
real-life scenarios what are you doing I
don't know good to you they really need
this though cuz they've been in jail for
20 years I don't know what's going on
the smartphone like my friend's brother
he was in the prison and when he got out
he told me that there's well this was in
2002 he told me that there are guys in
there that are so surprised about cell
phones and all these things because
there's guys that are in prison from the
60s or they're like what you could phone
a laptop yeah my banking bro oh yeah I
just figured out that [ __ ] yeah that's
nice like self-checkout that's [ __ ]
mind-blowing so I'm gonna show you guys
a clip this is on Vice so Vice visited
six inmates are going through this price
vices cue I thought there was a button
yeah I like rice but yeah melody was
going yeah I was I was I stopped myself
cuz my mind said should I promote
another play I don't know well I like
him but then you know what I said [ __ ]
it I'm just talking table okay go ahead
that's what happened shortened version
of the video you know what I would do I
start masturbating mm-hmm this father
will be a lot of hot girls in there
right well this is like real light like
it's real we on this cell phone yeah
well actually there's a merge as reality
and augmented reality okay here we go
why don't we try a self checkout now I'm
going to show you check out the grocery
store and pay for the groceries you're
buying using self checkout and the store
expresses the people like that yeah they
they do you know there's offices
sometimes someone standing around it's
just a way different world than the
world I remember it was in some ways
depressing how much of the world that
you've missed you know after he looks
like normal quarter century with what
you had on you could observe but you
weren't really interacting that much so
this is more about interacting this one
is how to do laundry yeah let's get
intro you looking for a fight no you
just bumped into me boys tall guys like
well what would you do if you're in that
situation well clearly I wouldn't be in
this bar cuz I'm a stab the [ __ ] out of
this mother okay well next scenario what
if he gets scared like is he gonna get
in trouble in the VR bar because he's on
parole awesome imagine they [ __ ]
trick him like that he's like you're in
a [ __ ] VR bar what the [ __ ] bro
that's violation cops coming in start
beating his ass in there I don't know
how to deal with that scenario yeah can
you imagine how mind-blowing that would
be like in 20 years you just go out to
the world your life and then seeing how
fast technology is evolving now compared
to back when they went into prison or
first
like let's say we all go to prison right
now and in 20 years from today like how
crazy that like life is gonna be 30
years from now yeah like how do you even
explain like uber to them like you're
telling me I'm not getting a stranger's
car
in the backseat and I'm not supposed to
pull my knife out and steal it it's
crazy it's like whoa get into your car
he takes a rock it's your car
but keys are in your head really because
you could just be like he doesn't even
know I don't think the world has changed
this is really good because I heard that
a lot of guys go back into prison
because they get intimidated by the
world they're not ready so they go back
out and they're like [ __ ] I got a I got
to pay my bills I got to get a job like
I had everybody taking care of me and
then they they just don't know what to
do so they purposely commit a crime to
go back in I hate responsibility man
that [ __ ] gives me anxiety
responsibility is pretty tough dude it
[ __ ] sucks I don't get a kid then man
yeah but yeah I'm not ready for that
yeah when I am I will be I just hate
responses we have girlfriends too that's
right yeah just handles all my
responsibilities she's awesome
because it's pretty what you're white
man at that point you know it's dope and
Bart's life he doesn't even know how to
turn on the washer and dryer I'm talking
about that yesterday I bought them shits
but he's like monkey like hutchings like
[ __ ] you could hear me huh yeah I'm
like just leave it I'll do it
he just gets it that question doing
laundry or trying to I need to wait what
do you mean cuz it's his dirty clothes
what look I bought those seven pairs of
Levi's that's what I'm saying I don't
have responsibility so [ __ ] funny
it's like it's to that point where it's
just like you're like babe today you're
my queen I'm gonna do the laundry all
yours
that's it don't don't don't don't
[ __ ] touch it leave it alone
just leave it alone just give me a
[ __ ] background did your shirts
already have seven punch holes in it no
you know what to prevent that though
whenever we have something me like we
just got the Apple TV you know showing
Casey like all congratulations I've been
trying to tell you guys to get that [ __ ]
forever you know finally we've got it
it's amazing you're so right I should
listen to you forever ago
so forever ago okay so anyway so then he
gets home I'm like okay honey come here
sit down I'm gonna teach you how to use
it because I don't want to hear you like
yelling at me from like downstair or
like if I'm downstairs you're yelling at
me like from the East Wing how do you do
that I'm like no I texted you you know
what happens we're actually genius
because we do know how to use it we just
pretend like we don't you just revealed
it to the girl world's you know
entertainment I know how to use it's
just tours I don't know how to use
mmm-hmm see I know but that's how we go
into training and then I walk him
through it but he's hands-on I'm very
hands-off so I'm like you figure it out
and I'll step in when I need to
I still don't remember I like staying in
the kitchen that's where I that's right
yeah make me a [ __ ] thing that's my
[ __ ] even in the house to when I'd be
cooking and I yesterday to a was like a
man so how do you make this ground
chicken because I usually do like
chicken lot whatever whatnot right and
I'm like yeah just put this in this in
heels okay I just keep standing on the
stove I might get the [ __ ] out I'm just
doing it so as I was cooking my tea I
just cooked his and it was just quicker
so you get the [ __ ] out here
let's do herself and then you changed
your pad yeah yeah but like I don't know
I just get frustrated I'm like I taught
you this already old you have two roles
like if he's really good at something
just let him take that over and it looks
right yes me and just like she's really
good at cleaning I'm really good at
cooking and I was just no it's not
really that it's more like oh where did
you put this thing or like how do you do
this and I'm like I taught you like 10
times
I gotta teach you again like how do you
tie your shoe no I like where do we keep
this thing now thank you where we keep
it
some people just have domains though
they're just good at their domain like
when I'm in the kitchen right and I see
somebody touch my knives I'm like don't
don't touch that [ __ ] you don't know how
to use it get the [ __ ] out that's how I
feel anyways alright I think that's
that's that's that's how it works in my
household that I can't touch nothing I'm
just kidding I don't want to I mean cuz
like I look at the way I fold and then I
look at Jess's and I'm like damn dude
this looks like I got mental problems
[Laughter]
like all the help and package do you
know you know how I fold this is my
fault
alright I go like this that's like the
bottom of a paper paper toilet wall for
thing is I don't I hate folding dude do
you do the store way you know like how
it looks like hold it exactly like that
David yeah that's how I do this is
literally what I do with mine how that
got to be soft I just do this that's all
I do
BAM done put it on now I do it this is
how I do it I go like this and I go
[Laughter]
alright today we're doing the laundry
you know how hard it is like my brain
bursts when I'm when I have to do stuff
like normal stuff like when I have to
arrange a TV so like okay like in the
mirror organizing
he kills it there yeah seems like
organizing cleaning things like this
gives me anxiety like not the mess but
thinking of where to put it away because
this is how I seriously clean and did
this for 30 minutes I move everything to
one side of the table and I got rid of
one thing and I came back and I was like
moving this back to the other side of
the table and I just moved it back and
forth and I was like Fogg I gotta throw
away something or do something with this
[Music]
[Music]